Hi guys good morning
Who's that? Who's that? Who's that?Who's that?
just kidding. aha
So today we are gonna
Go have some
breakfast so you guys are gonna join us while we go to IHOP and it's gonna be the first time we go to IHOP in
for-ever
We have a history with iHop though
We used to go to IHOP almost every single time we met up
like every single time
We would meet up, early dating days
Yeah, it would always be the IHOP by my house and Downey or the IHOP over here
Oh, yeah, or in Monterey Park
So it would always be these IHOPS that we would always go to and then that's how like we would bond
Like with Isaac remember we'd have breakfast and then we saw we'd go have breakfast important Gio in that time
And then we still always just have good time, so we are feeling a little nostalgic, so we're gonna go have some breakfast at i hop
at IHOP
Alright, so now we're on our way to go eat, and we are using our old camera for this vlog
So I don't know if you guys noticed if it looks different or not
But this is the first camera that we bought and the reason why we're using this camera is because as you guys have noticed
Our other camera has a dead pixel so towards the top ,a little red dot. it's been annoying a lot of you guys
So we're taking that camera in to get fixed, and we're using this old, baby. Put more red dots everywhere send our u-haul
Yeah, so that's why we're using the and the reason why we stopped using this camera
It's this camera gets on my nerves because it will it
Refuses to focus on the right things like sometimes like if I'm talking to the camera it will focus behind me
And I bet you anything at some point in this vlog. That's gonna happen
Well the one thing the one positive thing about this camera that I like over the other cameras we own is that this one is
Way more portable. It's like smaller, and it could just fit in my purse the other ones are too bulky. Yeah, so breakfast time
I'm hungry
look at that handsome mann
i havent been here in so long that this thing looks crazy to me right now // i know the menus are different
i was freezing as soon as i came in so casey went and got me a jacket
i got our coffee yum
I was showing it. We're gonna be quite a bit
And I really hope you can because it's really loud in here, but yeah, we're going to Vegas this weekend and just after breakfast we
American Red Cross and feel with the dummy blood
casey and i are gonna go
Lina's since we're trying to donate blood up to this I'm gonna try to get a meal
Because I read that iron-rich true red meat is part bad little
Don't have lenses here, but I'm gonna try to get like a for something with a big side is finished
I could really up my iron level I
Thought I was like why how come we got this small one there looked around at the other table as everyone has a small copper
thing
a
Big plate of spinach for my iron. This is a lot of food. I am 100% sure I'm not gonna finish this
To harvest raining night
I got pancakes too am I gonna finish all of the dishes and pancakes
I didn't expect to get hashbrowns so that's something I didn't know it's gonna be potatoes are cheap
All right so breakfast is over
It was delicious. Are you folding it very full and im sleepy
sleepy
I know I know we got it getting the itis so I did my best
Finishing what I could and I'm actually pretty proud of myself
Compared to how I how much I usually eat I eat a lot this time right yeah you do your appetites growing
is that a good thing or bad thing hehehe
Don't think it's growing. I think it was just today. Anyways. We're on our way now to the
American Red Cross earlier this week, I kept trying to book an appointment for us to go and donate blood in Las Vegas
Yeah in Las Vegas since we're going to Vegas like we wanted our blood to go directly to the victims
But and I called and they said that they don't have any appointments available
Until the end of October, so we're like okay, well we're not gonna be there at that time
But they did say that we can just go to any
Donation center and just donate our blood and no matter what what is always needed
so I did try to see if I can book an appointment for the
Center's around us or see if there's any blood drives around us, but everything around us is pretty booked
They did say on the website that walk-ins are welcome
So we're going to attempt to
Go to a donation center right now and see if they'll take us as a walk-in so fingers crossed that we're able
To donate today, and if not then we'll just make an appointment for later on this month
And then we'll just go back, so we're trying to do this before we go to Vegas
Like at least for me. I feel like it's like my moral responsibility since I'm a Type O
And I'm a universal donor I feel like I need to contribute like however much
I can going to a place that is you know in the midst of a crisis
And you know that's morning it feels wrong to go there and not be a part of the help exam
And it's not like we wouldn't want to help if we weren't going to Vegas you know
but it's because we're going there like first hand we have the chance to actually help right then and there as
The city is still coping with everything that's happened there
I feel compelled to you know donate what haven't donated blood in a long time now. I used to be really into
Donating blood when I was in high school
I really I called it you yeah, almost like every time there was a blood donation drive
I would definitely donate blood, and I don't know what happened like just being a grown-up
And then you know you get busy, and then you're looking out for number one
And you know you kind of have to make a living and grownup matters and interests
And you forget about the humanitary you know responsibility that you know you should be doing and so this is like for me
It's like a return to form before my innocence was lost
Being a grown-up
No for me. I always tried to donate blood at high in high school I alway
Time that there was a blood drive. I would go and sign up in every single time
They would deny me because I never weighed enough like I was always like 95 pounds you have to be at least
110 and now I am like a hundred and I think hundred and
I'm really like I'm barely making it
I remember a few years back my hospital that I was working in had a blood drive and again
I went and I attempted to see if I could donate blood
And they said that my iron levels were too low so I finally made the weight
but then my iron levels were too low so I'm like no so then I
waited again the next year that they came back and I made sure I ate a lot of spinach a lot of lentils and
eggs and like every iron-rich food that I could think of like I just
Ate as much as I could and so I'm like trying to do my best to make sure that I'm healthy enough
And you drink enough water. I did I should I'm drinking water right now
I still need a drink more, but hopefully they accept us. We'll see
You ready, let's do it
Get those veins ready, I'm not a very veiny person
They're gonna put like 5 holes in me today because it happens all the time. I end up getting like 5 boo-boos. Oh your boo-boos
Boo-boos
No, I'm super rainy
I have like the greatest veins ever like people that the phlebotomist they love by veins look at that one nice and fluffy
I'm ready. Let's do it. Let's go
All right, so we've just spent about an hour
Waiting to see if they could see us
But they said that they've been having a lot of people come in and people that have appointments obviously take priority over walk-ins
So we ended up making an appointment for later on this month
So we'll be back to donate now the plan is I'm gonna go get my nails done find some more frivolous things don't hate
Yeah
All right, I'm leaving. What are you doing? What's happening? He's the coffee from IHOP and the water
I was drinking to give blood. Okay. Bye. I gotta go okay
You're gonna see me with new nail colors
I'm thinking black since Halloween's coming up anyways, and I haven't had black nails since I was in my emo grunge stay
Bye cutie pie look at him I want to put my face in his belly
Jealous
Yeah, a little bit
that cute
Bye, right, I gotta be
Alright, I'm not to do my nails
All right, so I'm all done with my nails I ended up going with the matte black
You see the matte black the camera won't focus like always see what I tell you guys. I'm all focused there. We go a
matte black
We're getting ready for Halloween so if you guys are curious I get my nails with hard
Gel not just typical regular nail polish. It's not acrylic. It's not normal
gel its hardtail
So talking to all the ladies out there and know what I'm talking about because I know the guys are gonna be like huh?
It's not for you. It's for the girls so the hard gel. It's like this really thick substance
Gooey kind of thing that leave your nails feeling like it's acrylic
But it's healthier than acrylic apparently like it lets your nails breathe a little more
I'm not sure exactly the scientific thing about it, but my girl suggested to try hard gel so for the last
I would say maybe like about six months. I've been doing hard gel, and that's how I was able to grow up
my nose really long
So I don't have any fake tips on these are 100% mine except for the hard gel on top of it, so yeah
I mean I've been loving it. It's like way lighter like it
Just it just feels really sturdy cuz if I don't have anything on my nails like I give
It's just regular nail polish my nails break so easily
They're so brittle, so guess I need to take vitamins because I have really weak nails with the hard gentle
I think I get them done
Maybe like once every two months, so I get to come weigh less it is more expensive obviously than regular gel
But it's worth it for me so anyway so now that I'm done
I'm gonna stop by pick up some poop gift for the huffy, and then see what he's up to
Supposedly he's editing, but I bet you anything. He's just watching a whole bunch of trailers
Huh aren't you future Casey alright, so we're all done with lunch. Did you like your polka bebut?
See we hi oh
I mean, that's a yes
Yes, so we're all done with lunch now and what I really wanted to do was show you guys and also to show our future
Selves like you know I'm thinking like 20 years from now, and then we're looking back on these videos
I wanted to remember in video form our wedding gifts that we received because we have some really amazing
Friends family and fans who sent us things and I was really excited
I wanted to show you guys alright, so this first one we have here so this was given to Casey by a fan
Which I don't remember because there were a few bottles and then Bart and Joe got one too, and it is
Don't don't look don't look. I'm trying to take
Good like it's Perry Perry's up come on focus camera Mondo's peri-peri sauce
So that's for you have you ever had Nando's
I never have you never been to the hemisphere of the world where they have Nando's yet never I've only ever seen in Australia
I've heard this before what where they have Nando's all over the world and they even have like a challenge
Or if you visit every single location around the world you get like a permanent some sort of like membership or something
Yeah, so sorry fan who gave that to Casey? I don't remember who you were, but thank you
I will call him Perry Perry name is Perry nando as far as I'm concerned
Thanks, Perry, and then we got these gifts, which I haven't opened yeah
I just opened the box, but this is from Hannah from Sweden. This is a candle made in my hometown of
Boris sweet and me give you many wonderful smelling nights. You're so sweet Hannah
Thank you so much totally appreciate this. They're gonna smell this handle see what it sounds like oh cool
We have Swedish newspaper - I only have one hand
Help me
What a pretty candle it's not oh
It smells really good. Oh, what is it smells like?
Sweden Swedish
Neighbor hurt over City Boris, I'm a little obsessed with how people live lives elsewhere
So this newspaper is actually very interesting. I know it's pretty cool
She even gave us another mini present without knowing. Oh look at this blanket. Oh, can you help me again need your hand
This is so cool. It's so fluffy and soft, and oh yeah, it is like water is a
Spanish a little while ago, and this is for my cousin, Samantha who attended the wedding and she lives out in Paris
Thank you so much. Sammy. We already opened this present, but I wanted to show you guys Uncle Pete. She is
insanely thoughtful look at the same you guys have to see this look how cute
Very cute in case yours threw me on my hike man. Yep. She wrote such a sweet thing okay
I'm not gonna read. It is pretty long, but it's not like her writing though. She has a really nice Henry
Maybe you guys can just read it really quick on your own fun the Star Wars song starts now and go
Thank You Sammy you're so sweet
And then she also got a this bracelet from Paris
Created with love in Paris and his love and it's a cute little bracelet. It says French tea is Mary
I don't know what that means, but I think this this brand is like
Marriage team Paris teatime. I don't know France is known for tea
Irby tea oh
I kind of smells. I don't know that's giving the candle records money smells pretty good
Also
Super cool, Tagalog, and then she's like for your future travels together isn't that so thoughtful?
And then we can like scratch off where we've been and it's like a whole book thing and then we can plan our trips
I'm definitely gonna be using this and then
She also threw in here this
Already opened it
I thought it was a no these people know that that's a bag to keep you on airplanes for you to throw up in
I don't know
Yeah, and then we got some more candles it's like limey like zesty
Mm-hmm lemony fresh, that's what we got from my cousin, Samantha
And then our good friends their company name is I loot papery
And steal the paper their paper pant bend
It's so cute their whole branding
so I'm gonna put the link in the description you have to check out their cards what they do they have a company and they
Make these super super adorable cards, or best wishes or out-of-this-world adventures together
And it says just married and so they create these cards
It's so cute, and they wrote us like a really sweet message, and then it says cards you guys can write to Isaac
como se llaman
Rato is acute
Acute is cars. So this one is for Tiffany to write to Casey
Services for me to write to you says job well done. You're in rare form
Because I like food. There's no one I like better than you I
Love our you like no other I do you bacon me crazy. I lie down
I'm fuck you too. Cute little art last but not least here. We have
Or case you to write for Tiffany. Let's Mack and be cheesy. Oh, that's a cool
you're a fine pizza I
Like that one. Do ya you so foxy you foxy I've got nothing but love for you
So if you guys are looking for really cute adorable
cards to send to your and not your typical hallmark type stuff
Yeah, that's it
I want to show you guys what we got and then oh
Wait and then this thing to go Casey's friend from Dallas who went to our wedding
Along with his wife not he gifted us this beautiful cutting board that he made himself
And then he carved out a TNC and then the wedding date, which is so thoughtful
and it was
Really sweet of them to do that because we had told everyone that went to the wedding like please don't worry about giving this gift
Like we just you guys being there is enough for us the fact that dick did that was really really sweet
Oh, you know who else gave us something. It's upstairs next to our TV. Oh yeah, we're in G other
Um what do you call it sound bar is that our do bar?
Thing but it pretty much gives us surround sound doesn't it with that thing
Yeah, because remember I put on the the head thing
And then I have to like then in different parts of the room so it could like
Thank you for in geo for that wouldn't present to then and then up obviously in cases family who gave him this beautiful bracelet
beautiful
Necklace that I never take off and then Casey's parents gifted us
Some hula. Thank you
What about me what about I give you I gave you something you gave me your life
And then when I give you huh biome yeah
So those are our wedding presents. We're we're so blessed, baby